good morning John it is you're younger
but still quite old brother Han so
sometime in the last 10 years it became
pretty normal to talk about parasocial
relationships they've always been a
thing when I was in high school I was
obsessed with Gordon goo and Helen Hunt
you can have a parasocial relationship
with fictional characters stretch far
back enough people had parasocial
relationships with like Zeus and emis
Def find this term that I keep using a
parasocial relationship is basically
when the parts of your brain that are
designed to have a social relationship
between you and another person are used
to just have a relationship with a
person who does does not know who you
are or cannot know who you are because
they Huckleberry F who was not for
clarity a real person John you and I
always have big talks about all of the
things that we do and how weird it is
something that we've been talking a lot
about didn't really fall into place
until I heard Britney brosi say this on
Colin and samir's show having such an
intense parasocial relationship honestly
from my end and from their end because
I'm parasocial attached to them in a
different way than they sort of look to
me for a pickme up or for Content or for
the big sister Vibe every decision I
make is for them I don't want to have
them be mad at me or be unhappy with the
content I'm putting out I think it's
unacceptable to not be attached to your
audience I have always known that I have
a very strong very real very important
relationship with the people who I do
not know who consume this content just
like you can have a relationship with a
character in a book I have a parasocial
relationship with this thing that I have
created in my head I have vented it and
it is a thing that I can never fully
know or understand and I call it nerd
Feria now this is a parasocial
relationship but it's not usually what
we mean when we say parasocial
relationship cuz it's going in the other
direction and there's not really a word
for that but yesterday when you and I
were talking about this on the phone you
John called it a serap poal relationship
which is got to be the best possible
term so to talk about it for a sec this
is obviously a very tricky relationship
to maintain first of all because check
this out
the people who make up this community
are different people they they have
different upbringings and they live in
different places and they have different
values and they care about different
things but also they are more similar to
each other than like the broader body of
humanity there are some things that tie
us together there is a core and I don't
know what holds the core together but
the things that hold the core together
are important and I think about them a
lot and I try to understand it by
talking to people in the real world by
reading comments by doing the nerd f
sensus and the building of an
understanding of what ties us together
like what is exciting what is unexpected
and expected what is unacceptable that
is a constant thrumming in my brain that
informs everything that I make also I
can't control the core but I do like
want things for the core I want it to be
strong and dense and capable and what
does that mean strong I guess just like
that there's shared values that do knit
it together and even when there 's
conflict you check back in on those
values and you can say well we're
disagreeing about this thing but this
thing we still agree about density for
me means that there are lots of
different shared things like maybe not
everybody shares the same things but
there are lots of different things that
we do share and those things are not
found often or as much outside of the
core so like they're they're special
things and I want those things to be
like unassailably good and some of those
things you can control like the average
nerd fighter is going to know a lot more
about tuberculosis
and pelicans and AFC Wimbledon than the
average human but some of those things
are going to like arise naturally like
the the number of trans or non-binary
nerd Fighters is much higher than the
general population the number of people
who voted for Donald Trump is much lower
than the general population we didn't
set out to have a lot of non-binary
people in the space or exclude Trump
voters it just happened naturally the
last adjective I use and I literally
this was off the top of my head so
there's plenty of other things I could
say here but is capable and by capable I
think you know what it means like the
the most interesting and best part of
being uh a part of this thing is that it
can do things for itself and for the
world I want it to feel valuable to be a
member of this community because it is
and I want it to feel like this
community can do stuff together whether
that's increase access to tuberculosis
treatments and tests or it's Crash
Course insid show or the awesome socks
and awesome coffee clubs uh raising lots
of money to increase access to maternal
Healthcare and cerly young a lot of
those things have this core as their
Foundation but then can grow Way Beyond
that and do way more good in the world
than they could if they if it never left
the core that's capable that's amazing
that's powerful but also did you see
this coming there are hard Parts I have
for a long time now considered myself to
be not mine
between this relationship uh and also
relationship like the the obligation to
various companies and other stakeholders
of those companies and then of course my
family and my friends parts of myself
that were for me I I lost I'd lost them
now for clarity I think it is very
important and an absolute good to share
a great deal of yourself I think that a
self shared is a much more Rich
existence than a self that is only for
one self but it's also good to have some
self left for the self and that was
something that other people always
forced me into rather than something
that I would do voluntarily that has
changed some since I got sick for
reasons that you could probably guess at
which I think is probably healthy
something else that makes a sarap poal
relationship hard I've already kind of
referred to but it's that there's a
bunch of different people and sometimes
they're going to disagree with each
other and so you have a relationship
with a thing that doesn't agree with
itself which can also sometimes happen
when you just have a relationship with a
person sometimes I don't agree with
myself part of the center might think
that it is absolutely ludicrous for
someone to spend a lot of time on on Tik
Tok which is a strange organization to
let have a huge amount of data about you
and I understand that a piece of the
core would feel that way and a piece of
the core would disagree I think the core
has disagreed about how and whether to
separate art from the person who created
that art but you got to hold space for
the reality that disagreement is okay
and normal and in fact healthy like if
every single person agreed on every
single thing I think we'd have a problem
and like one thing that we've talked
about before John is that like you and I
don't feel comfortable being the
deciding voice of that of saying like
Okay we're having a disagreement here's
the solution because one I don't trust
myself enough to wield that power and
two the people who disagree with us
would then feel alienated and unwelcome
in a place that they love all this is to
say this is a thing and it's weird it's
more common now than it ever has been uh
because of the structure of the internet
and I'm grateful to Britney and you John
for helping me think through all of it
even after all these years I like I'm I
still am working on it like I still am
confused by it and it's hard and I think
like the serosal relationship is
actually a much bigger deal than the
parasocial relationship in that person's
life because it's not just a
relationship it is also like a job it's
like an everpresent thing in my mind
everything I do is informed by it not
everything thank goodness but like
everything public now I do not know
whether to attribute this to the the
initial values that we started out with
or to our constant stressing about it or
to Pure dumb luck or to the individual
people who make up the community or just
all of the above but we have a
tremendous core like we have one of the
most interesting cores out there maybe
the most interesting most effective like
there's probably some competition but it
doesn't feel like that to me I could not
wish for a better group of people to be
in this with even if it is weird and
confusing sometimes John I'll see you on
Tuesday